Some quick fire questions about my Cyrex array 10 food allergy results
Limes and lemons are okay, but oranges are not do you know what they make the modified citrus pectin up any idea if that's okay to take no
I don't know that might have to call the company to see
But I'm pretty sure the modified citrus pectin does not contain limes or lemons
In it it's the pectin from the citrus. I don't I don't know we might have to call the company to see again
Anything which it is questionable. It's it's okay to
Leave that off the list of consumables right now
So this would be something that would fall in the questionable range even if we called the company and asked them
Might not get the answer that we want. It's like, okay. Well, I'm just gonna go on with this for a while
Tofu is the only protein that's okay in my list. I know that Dr. Chen Jen says tofu is okay. What do you think?
I'm not a fan of that especially if you have ER or PR positive cancer tofu is made of soy
Even if it's organic tofu not GMO tofu, it can still stimulate soy
It's not a fermented product. I would leave that off the list
Apples are in the yellow zone, but apple cider is in the greens. Oh, do you know if apple cider vinegar would be okay?
If I don't know that vinegar was tested and know that apple cider vinegar wasn't tested if
Apple cider vinegar would probably be okay
So that would probably be okay